en vingt paquets pour toi
[Musique]
que tout le monde sorte
écoutez moi
[Musique]
bonjour lieutenant bronx
savez vous où seront collègues policiers
gilles saux
je croyais que gillot était mort c'est
le gars
[Musique]
trophée type t'as pas une seconde
comment je vais le coincer si je peux
faire confiance à personne dans cette
[ __ ] de regardes tu n'y arriveras pas
seul
celui qui a fait ça une autre motivation
c'est plus personnel
c'est quand la dernière fois que tu as
vu ton père
[Musique]
[Rires]
un imitateur de jx oh ça va pas être
facile
[Musique]
mais c'est juste une diversion pour agir
tranquille dans le commissariat
je veux tout le monde sur cette affaire
il peut être n'importe ans ça peut être
n'importe qui
on va retourner toute la ville
bonjour l'ambiance
quelle est la dernière fois où vous avez
vu votre père
[Musique]